vite benjamin et puis mes jambes de
jeune homme dit grand air pourquoi tu
m'emmènes souvent par ici
le bonheur d'entendre à nouveau la voix
du tourangeau jean carmet nous sommes
assemblant ces et c'est ici qu'une
incroyable histoire a commencé il y a
maintenant 30 ans voici l'histoire de la
scéno ferry de la légende de la source
un spectacle qui a fait aussi sa
réputation par ces incroyables costumes
elles sont plus d'une vingtaine de
petites mains à y travailler toute
l'année
arlette champions et la responsable des
costumes depuis 30 ans n'est pas
professionnel on est tous des passionnés
de la couture donc du coup chacun savait
faire des petites choses chez soi et en
fait on a appris ensemble à faire mes
costumes de la scène aux ferries ses
couturières costumière avec le temps
sont devenus inséparables il n'engendre
pas la mélancolie même quand elles ont
été obligées en 2002 refaire lui sans
costume détruit dans un incendie
qu'à cela ne tienne la plupart d'entre
elles sont aussi comédienne dont le
spectacle anne rameaux des costumières
comédienne
c'est du bénévolat mais on y prend
plaisir et puis a joué qu est ce que
vous les applaudissements merci pour les
applaudissements où les gens qui tapent
des pieds à la fin non on est content
moi c'est ma deuxième vie puisque j'ai
commencé ma retraite il ya vingt ans et
je vis c'est noger engager mes petits
enfants pour venir jouer avec moi
pendant les vacances enfin bon c'est une
deuxième vie n'y a pas de doute
trois mille costumes pour six ans
comédien car tous sont plusieurs roule
alors il faut toujours améliorer créé
renouveler réparer une chute de tissus
devient vite un habit surtout que
l'histoire du spectacle traversent les
siècles
on commence par l'époque de la
malle-poste on appelle ça l'époque de la
malle poste et après il ya un retour en
arrière de l'époque gallo romaine
jusqu'à la révolution
et effectivement il faut des costumes
donc gallo romain il faut des costumes
de barbares aussi juste après les gallo
romains il ya des barbares il faut des
costumes médiévaux
après la renaissance après louis xiv
après le 18e le siècle des lumières qui
est assez important dans notre spectacle
et on a un tableau assez fantastique
qu'est le tableau de la révolution
[Musique]